ils sont partout plus monstrueux que
jamais insectes gluant face de vampire
au pouvoir maléfique si puissant que
personne ne résiste surtout pas les
petits anges j'ai aussi acheté un petit
fantôme qui tremble donc quand on entre
il se met à trembler il fait comme
çaou c'est effrayant donc c'est c'est
bien les histoires de sorcière ont
toujours séduit les enfants sages la
nouveauté c'est que les démons du
marketing exploitent le filon dans les
rayons jeunesse des librairies le
bestseller est une série de pouvante
américaine il veut être le plus fort
envers les sorcières envers tout donc
c'est normal et il y arrive ah
difficilement mais bon ça correspond à
un besoin que ressentent les enfants
d'exorciser leurs peurs personnelles
enfin leurs peurs intérieures et de
projeter sur des objets qu'il
manipulent toutes leur toutes leurs
crainte en même temps de cette façonl il
les annulent